hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to terror lab flashbang
Randy good god man what did I do
time to recover memories I'm gonna call
you Chad
and I don't want to talk about holes
when I'm around you Chad you know though
it was just an experimental time in
college Chad we were just having a
bromance and you you made it all weird
Chad
you make me feel things that I don't
want to feel make me think about times
that I don't want to think about anymore
all of our bro moments are bromans we
had a great time growing out in the
woods
that's woods in bro speak you stab good
times back in our early party days and I
know I know Stacy got in between both of
us literally and figuratively just
thought this was a door I thought I was
making a dramatic exit there again that
does not help anybody it just blinds me
I'm flash banging myself you'll never
see me coming
I had you don't swath away